en el último vídeo nos quedamos en 1902
y 1903 cuando la genética mendeliana fue
redescubierta en el cambio de siglo y
volver y sharon de forma independiente
habían propuesto la teoría cromosómica
que dice que los cromosomas son el lugar
donde estos factores hereditarios de los
cuales mendel habló por primera vez se
encuentran pero dijimos en este vídeo
que eso era sólo una teoría estaba
basada en observaciones de la meiosis y
ver cómo se comportaban los cromosomas y
parecían comportarse de manera sana lo
gas a algunos de estos factores
hereditarios pero en realidad no tenían
buenas pruebas celulares de que los
cromosomas fueron la ubicación para
estos factores hereditarios y comenzamos
a tener pruebas acerca de esto cuando
estudiamos el trabajo de thomas hunt
morgan en 1908 él decide estudiar moscas
de la fruta pero porque decide estudiar
moscas de la fruta bueno si alguna vez
has visto una mosca de la fruta son muy
muy pequeñas así que en realidad podrías
tener un montón de moscas de la fruta en
un frasco por lo tanto es conveniente
muchas veces no se piensa en la
logística de la ciencia pero se pueden
poner muchas de ellas en un frasco eran
baratas y esa es otra de las
preocupaciones de la ciencia ya que no
siempre se tienen muchos recursos para
hacer investigación tenían una vida
corta y se reproducían mucho por lo que
se podía tener muchos descendientes
rápidamente y muchas generaciones si se
quería estudiar cómo los diferentes
rasgos son transmitidos o no son
transmitidos y así él comenzó a trabajar
con las moscas de la fruta en 1908 y
criaba las moscas en busca de algún tipo
de rasgo mutante en general cuando nos
fijamos en los rasgos de una especie el
tipo salvaje también conocido como el
tipo natural o el tipo silvestre el tipo
silvestre es el que típicamente se ve
mientras que el rasgo mutante es poco
común
y después de dos años él finalmente
descubre un rasgo mutante en sus moscas
de la fruta él encuentra un macho con
ojos blancos así que este es el macho de
ojos blancos por aquí y dice esto es
interesante voy a cruzar a esta mosca
macho de ojos blancos con las moscas
hembras y te puedes estar preguntando
cómo logró hacer que eso ocurriera pues
bien se toma un frasco lleno de moscas
hembras y se pone el macho de ojos
blancos dentro del frasco y así ocurre
la cruza y lo interesante fue el patrón
hereditario que observó para este rasgo
de ojos blancos tenemos a la generación
de los padres aquí pero en la generación
f1 todas las hembras tenían los ojos
rojos y todos los machos tenían los ojos
rojos
y así con esta primera generación no
estaba claro si algo interesante estaba
pasando pero luego cruzo estas moscas
unas con otras y solo que algunos de
ustedes pueden estar pensando que nos
están cruzando entre hermanos y hermanas
buenos y posiblemente eran medios
hermanos y hermanas si provenían de
diferentes madres y algunos de ellos
podrían haber sido hermanos y hermanas
en realidad eso es de lo que la gente
habla cuando se dice que se está
cruzando a la generación f1
pero cuando cruzaron estas moscas entre
sí él vio un patrón bastante interesante
vio una proporción de ojos rojos con
respecto a los ojos blancos de 3 a 1 es
decir que por cada cuatro moscas de la
fruta había tres de ojos rojos y uno de
ojos blancos por lo que el rasgo de ojos
blancos reaparece en esta generación lo
que por sí mismo es interesante esto
demuestra que este rasgo puede ser
transmitido genéticamente y eso es
interesante porque ésta era una mutación
que apareció después de que él hizo
observaciones a lo largo de muchas
muchas muchas generaciones de moscas
pero lo que es aún más interesante de
esta proporción 3 a 1 y esta proporción
3 a 1 es algo que apareció mucho en la
genética mendeliana pero lo que es aún
más interesante fue que sólo observó los
ojos blancos en los machos de esta
generación
efe 2 en esta segunda generación
y puedes estar pensando y porque eso es
importante bueno él era una persona muy
astuta y decía si estoy viendo este
rasgo solo en los machos y no es como
que sólo hubiera tenido cuatro moscas en
esta generación él pudo haber tenido
cientos de ellas pero en la proporción
de dos hembras de ojos rojos por un
macho de ojos rojos por un macho de ojos
blancos y así en toda esta generación él
solo observó los ojos blancos en los
machos y dijo tal vez de alguna manera
está relacionado con el cromosoma que
determina el sexo y así él dijo vamos a
suponer que si se trata de eso vamos a
suponer que ese rasgo que el alelo
mutante que la variación mutante del gen
para el color de ojos vamos a suponer
que es transportado en el cromosoma x
y así el genotipo de la primera mosca
mutante ese macho de ojos blancos que
encontré o podríamos llamarlo y esta es
la anotación que las personas suelen
utilizar porque se trata de un gen que
estamos asumiendo que está ligado al
sexo que se encuentra en un cromosoma
sexual en este caso el cromosoma x la
forma en que se especificaría el
genotipo de ese macho de ojos blancos es
el siguiente en su cromosoma x tenía la
variación blanca tenía el alelo blanco
la variación blanca de ese gen y le
ponemos la letra w
debido a la palabra blanco en inglés
white
y luego en su cromosoma jay es no tenía
ninguna variación para ese gen por lo
que suponemos que solo está contenida en
el cromosoma x probablemente has oído
hablar de homocigotos o heterocigotos
bueno este es un caso de un emmy cigoto
solo se tiene una versión del alelo en
uno de sus dos cromosomas uno de los dos
que se obtienen de cada uno de los
padres por lo que este sería el genotipo
del macho de ojos blancos el genotipo de
la hembra de ojos rojos se especifica de
esta manera tenemos el cromosoma x y las
hembras tienen dos cromosomas x al igual
que en los seres humanos por lo que en
cada uno de los cromosomas x suponemos
que las hembras comienzan con el alelo
rojo y la anotación para el alelo rojo
es w +
wv más y podrías decir bueno porque no
se utiliza la letra r bueno podríamos
hacerlo pero la convención general de la
genética es utilizar la letra del primer
tipo mutante descubierto para este gen y
luego usar este símbolo además para el
tipo silvestre y w que es el primer
alelo mutante descubierto para este gen
y que nosotros nombramos de esta manera
debido a la palabra blanco en inglés
white por lo que este es el alelo blanco
y estos representan a los alelos de
color rojo así que este es el genotipo
de la hembra de ojos rojos y así cuando
se cruza esa primera generación el macho
de ojos blancos ya sea que produzca
espermatozoides que tienen el cromosoma
x que van a contener el alelo o
y que no van a contener el alelo y las
hembras de ojos rojos producen óvulos
que independientemente de cuál de esos
cromosomas contengan ambos van a tener
el alelo de tipo silvestre
podemos ver cómo ocurren las cruzas se
podría tener un cromosoma x de ambos
padres si se tiene un cromosoma x de
ambos padres se va a tener una hembra ya
que va a ser xx y cada una de estas
hembras ya que tienen un tipo silvestre
y un tipo mutante y el tipo salvaje
resulta ser dominante su fenotipo sigue
siendo de ojos rojos pero ahora son
heterocigotos tienen el alelo blanco
ahora bien la descendencia masculina
para ser machos deben tener el cromosoma
jet de su padre así que no pueden tener
el alelo blanco y tienen el rojo el tipo
silvestre de su madre se puede ver aquí
y es por eso que todos los machos en esa
primera generación tenían los ojos rojos
ellos solo recibieron una copia del
alelo de tipo silvestre de su madre pero
entonces lo interesante son las cruzas
que se ven en la siguiente generación si
tomó estas hembras de ojos rojos que ya
dijimos que todas ellas son
heterocigotos se puede ver que tienen
rojo y tienen el alelo blanco y las
cruzó con machos de ojos rojos que es lo
que va a pasar pues bien las hembras de
esta generación con el fin de ser una
hembra deben de tener un cromosoma x de
su madre y de su padre así que obtiene
una equis de su padre que tiene el tipo
silvestre ahí el alelo rojo dominante
por lo que independientemente de cuál de
ellos recibieron de su madre las hembras
van a seguir teniendo los ojos rojos
algunas de ellas van a ser homocigotos y
algunas de ellas van a ser heterocigotos
pero ahora vemos que ocurre algo
interesante con los machos puede haber
machos emmys y gatos donde tienen el
cromosoma x rojo les madre o puede haber
machos emmys y gatos de ojos blancos que
tienen el alelo x blanco de su madre y
esta es exactamente la observación que
morgan hizo así que fue una cosa muy
interesante que él fue capaz de ver y
empezó la crianza de estas
en 1908 no fue sino hasta un par de años
después que finalmente encontró ese
primer macho de ojos blancos mutante y
fue en 1910 y 1911 que publicó estos
descubrimientos en la revista 'nature' y
la razón por la que esto es muy
importante es que sus observaciones son
completamente compatibles con este rasgo
de los ojos este gen que se encuentra en
el cromosoma x así que él fue capaz de
demostrar una relación directa entre en
este caso los cromosomas sexuales y los
factores hereditarios de los que mental
habló por primera vez y él continúa
trabajando junto con sus estudiantes por
muchos muchos muchos años y recibió un
premio nobel por este trabajo y esto es
muy importante porque él es finalmente
capaz de encontrar conexiones bastante
sustanciales entre estos factores
hereditarios de méndez la teoría de
volver y sara que dice que tal vez los
cromosomas tienen algo que ver con estos
factores hereditarios
y está demostrando que este es realmente
el caso estos cromosomas sexuales o en
este caso en particular el cromosoma
sexual x parece contener el gen para el
color de ojos en estas moscas de la
fruta